PROFESSOR: This idea
of social practice
is one that a lot of
theorists and critics
have talked about
and tried to frame.
I think of social
practice as an engagement
in art-making within a more
recent contemporary moment,
although there are historical
antecedents perhaps
many decades prior to now.
We might think, in, relatively
speaking, last 30 to 50 years,
some of these pieces
start to come together.
But one person
who I've looked at
to help theorize this
notion of social practice
is educator and
artist Pablo Helguera.
Helguera says--
unlike social work
that aims for
betterment of humanity,
defending human dignity,
and strengthening
human relationships, a socially
engaged artist may subscribe
to those same values but
make work that ironizes,
problematizes, and even
enhances the tensions
around those subjects in
order to provoke reflection.
So it's that end
part of the phrase--
to provoke reflection-- that
I bring into the classroom
or that I try to center some of
my work around this idea of--
what might we do to
provoke reflection,
not only in other people,
but also in myself?
Perhaps the work becomes a
provocation in that sense.
And why would we
want to do that?
Well, Helguera says we
want to do that perhaps
to discover something
in the process.
These artists, he
considers them--
renames them-- free
agents, if you will.
They insert themselves
into the most unexpected
social environments.
And they do so in
ways that break away
from disciplinary
boundaries, hoping
to discover something
new in the process.
So the idea of inserting
oneself into an unexpected place
or to perform a certain behavior
or certain interaction when
it's not expected,
we would do that
hoping to discover
something in the process.
So these two terms--
socially engaged art
and social practice--
are connected.
Helguera prefers
socially engaged art
because it still has
that word art in it.
He shortens it to be SEA.
But this idea of social
practice is a wider range,
is a term that seems to be a
bit more widely encompassing
of the range of practices that
might fit those definitions.
So to go on, just a couple
of more bits from Helguera.
Again, there are other folks
like Claire Bishop and Grant
Kester and other folks
who theorize and talk
about socially engaged art.
But I find Helguera's
approach quite useful.
So he talks about
socially engaged art
or social practice
as a multi-layered
and a participatory engagement.
He says that there
are these structures--
multiple structures
or multiple layers--
among which are
nominal participation,
directed participation,
creative participation,
and collaborative.
So there might be multiple
ways to participate or engage
the public or other individuals
within this practice.
Helguera also talks about the
idea of how these practices are
linked to other disciplines.
Specifically, we find
tension between art practice
and sociology, or
social practice.
But that trying to make sense
of those tensions and say it's
more art, it's like 85% this, or
16% of this something-- that's
not what he's talking about.
He says we want to stay
in that unresolved space.
It comes at us perhaps
through a sense
of art practices and
disciplinary considerations.
But that we want to remain
in that unresolved space.
We want it to be a bit messy.
So here's a bit of a
longer one, and then we'll
move beyond some
of the theorizing.
Helguera says social
interaction occupies
a central and inextricable
part of any socially engaged
artwork.
You've got to have the
social interaction.
Just doing something and
then hang it up and not
having other people
become participants at one
of those layers is not enough.
Although one might
argue that any artwork
is a socially engaged practice.
Once you put, let's say,
a painting or a sculpture
out to be seen, at least
one person is seeing it.
It's already an engaged
in a social relationship.
But Helguera goes further.
He says socially engaged art
is a hybrid, multidisciplinary
activity that exists somewhere
between art and non-art.
And what has to happen is,
you have to have actual--
and not hypothetical,
not imagined--
social action.
You actually have to
engage with other people.
So last week outside in
front of the building,
we created ceramic
water filters.
We mixed clay and
sawdust, and we
had several people stop by
to see what we were up to,
get their hands dirty.
We brought that mixture of
clay and sawdust back upstairs.
And we made ceramic
water filters.
And these water filters will
render contaminated water
with microbes and pathogens,
it will render it potable.
And so this practice of
performing the construction
and the production of
ceramic water filters
fits within Helguera's notion
of socially engaged art.
So I'm telling you that is
kind of a back step to what we
did last week, but also to
give you a specific example.
But then I want to give
you some other examples.
And some of the examples
that I want to share with you
push this idea of
telling stories that
might not be told otherwise.
I was in a course.
I was teaching a course a few
years ago to undergraduate art
education students.
We're trying to make sense
of-- what is it that art does?
Why are we teaching art?
What is the central
importance, or what
seems to be at the core?
Not that there might
be a singular core.
But there could
be multiple cores.
And one of the students
said, you know what?
I think art allows us to tell
stories that we would not
be able to tell otherwise.
In some ways, we might
not be able to tell them,
or we probably shouldn't tell
them otherwise as completely
through art practice.
And so I kind of
latch onto that.
But I'd like to add
the difficult stories.
The work that I try
to do is interested
in those difficult stories that
might not be told otherwise.
Not that they're
not told, but they
wouldn't be told
in the same ways
that socially engaged
art would do that.
So as I think
about this approach
to telling difficult stories, I
think of the word double-take--
when you see something and
then you have to look again.
This is a double-take, right?
You see it once, but it
caused you to stop and take
a second look.
We might think of
research in the same way.
We can search.
But when we research,
we search again.
It's to look again, to
do this double-take.
I also appreciate the
idea of making trouble.
Not only the idea of
troubling something
through the making of objects
or the making of experiences
or making of social actions,
but the making of trouble
in the idea of troubling
things that others
have made, whether they be
objects or social constructs
or ideologies.
So it's this idea of trouble
making and making trouble
that I like to play with.
And there's still images from
one of the Marx Brothers films
where Harpo and Groucho,
essentially the mirror breaks,
and they're
mirroring each other.
So there's all this
double-take going on.
They're looking
and looking again.
And so you have this idea
of visuality happening,
the perspective of the viewer.
But it's through this
social interaction.
And there a number of
iterations of that Marx Brothers
mirror scene that
play out in cartoons,
that play out in other stories.
So other ways that I've made
trouble in the past was--
and to think about
what we're seeing
and how we're seeing it--
was to take a look at February.
Quite often, I have been
invited to give talks
at schools or at
other institutions.
And they like to bring
me in in February.
I guess it's because February
is the month of Valentine's Day,
and they know that I'm a
very passionate person.
But if they look more
closely at my work,
they say I deal with
some difficult issues,
and not the least of which
is the construct of racism.
And that's also the month where
you have Black History Month.
And so I'm pretty sure
that's why they bring me in.
So if we look at February
a bit differently,
if we engage with
that month, not only
is it the month where we--
let's look at a specific
group of others,
which suggests there is another
construct against which we are
situating African-Americans.
But also the idea
of February being
the month for Valentine's
Day, is it's shortest month
of the year.
And the shortest
month of the year
is the year we say-- go tell
other people how much you
love them.
I mean, you would think a
month with 31 days would
be a better choice for that.
Or maybe all year
long we should think
in more passionate
and considerate ways.
So this is the work I
did a number of years
ago that revolved around
those two concepts.
I also am interested in
this idea of disruption.
I mentioned this
briefly last week.
And I think disruption
happens in a number of ways--
pushing back, questioning.
I'm interested in questioning
answers rather than answering
questions.
One of the ways I've done that
is, I've looked at barber shops
as pedagogical spaces,
as curriculum spaces.
What can we learn
in a barber shop?
And I wrote an article
about Pat's Barber Shop
in Norfolk, Virginia.
And I tried to make
the case that what
happens in a barbershop is a
hyper-textual, multi-layered,
multifaceted, learner-centered
space of inquiry.
That you might go in
trying to get a haircut,
but you come out
with an education.
And this happens in all
sorts of service locations--
hair salons and other places
where conversation becomes
essential to those locations.
I've also written about
digital technology.
When my wife and I
learned we were expecting
our birth of our daughter,
I started to think-- well,
that's fantastic.
And I thought--
oh, my goodness I'm
going to be someone's parent.
And, oh, I need to
think this through now.
This is a big deal.
So I started writing
myself a series of emails
to explain to our unborn
child who I thought I was
and what I was working through.
And so that series
of emails became
an article, or a chapter, an
email from a digital daddy.
And I was trying to
make sense of how
her future existence and
identity would be mediated
through digital technology.
But what came through in
the process of that was her
multi-ethnic identity and the
ways that I imagined camera
technology,
surveillance technology,
being scrutinized at airports--
among other approaches--
would render her body
the object of examination.
I want to shift now to tell
you a story about Henry Brown.
I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the Henry Brown who
I think about quite often.
Henry Brown lived in
Virginia outside of Richmond
in Henrico County.
And there's Henry in the middle.
He's inside this
box, and there's
some people outside the box.
So I guess they're
thinking outside the box.
And the story of Henry
Brown was told by himself.
He narrated this
story of himself.
And there are many
versions, or at least it
was published in a number
of different contexts,
in a number of
different formats.
And so Henry Brown earned
the name Henry Box Brown.
He was in that box for a reason.
I'm going to let you know
why in just a second.
I brought-- I didn't
bring them in.
We have obtained a
couple of pallets.
And I put the wooden
pallets on the floor here.
So you have these two
wooden pallets on the floor.
And I want to read you a story.
It's not a story that I wrote.
Henry wrote it.
But it's been retold and
is retold by Ellen Levine.
And the story is "Henry's
Freedom Box: A True Story
from the Underground Railroad."
The reason that I'm reading
this to you on these pallets--
what you see are two
pallets and this book
that I put on a sidewalk in
the middle of campus last year.
And I let it sit there
for 10 minutes or so.
And then I sat on the pallets,
and I read this story the way
I'm going to read it to you.
And people walked by.
Some of them stopped and
listened, and others did not.
Henry's Freedom Box--
Henry Brown wasn't
sure how old he was.
Henry was a slave, and
slaves weren't allowed
to know their birthdays.
Henry and his brothers and
sisters worked in the big house
where the master lived.
Henry's master had been good
to Henry and his family.
But Henry's mother knew
things could change.
Do you see those leaves
blowing in the wind?
They're from the trees
like the slave children
are torn from their families.
One morning, the master called
for Henry and his mother.
They climbed the wide staircase.
The master lay in the bed with
only his head above the quilt.
He was very ill.
He beckoned them to come closer.
Some slaves were
freed by their owners.
Henry's heart beat fast.
Maybe the master
would set him free.
But the master said,
you're a good worker Henry.
I'm giving you to my son.
You must obey him
and never tell a lie.
I will mail myself to a place
where there are no slaves,
he said.
Henry, are you all
right in there?
All right, he answered.
The cover was pried open.
Henry stretched and stood up.
Four men smiled at him.
Welcome to Philadelphia.
At last, Henry had a birthday--
March 30, 1849, his
first day of freedom.
And from that day on, he
also had a middle name.
Everyone called him
Henry Box Brown.
So this is the
story of Henry Box
Brown as told in a children's
book by Ellen Levine.
And it was illustrated
by Kadir Nelson.
Why did I read
that story to you?
Well, I wanted you to hear
the story of Henry Box Brown
not the way that he told
it, but the way that it
was retold for children.
That's a children's book.
It's meant to be
a children's book.
It's meant for children
to hear that story.
And it's a story that I've
read as a bedtime story
to our daughter.
There are different versions
of Henry's Freedom Box,
different children's versions
and different adult versions
of telling this story.
There are art approaches too.
There's a monument to Henry
Brown in Richmond, Virginia.
And this is a sculpture
made out of metal.
The same dimensions as
that box that Henry was in.
And etched in the
ground, it says,
"In a wooden crate
similar to this one,
Henry Brown, a Richmond
tobacco worker,
made the journey from
slavery to freedom in 1849."
And that box is interesting
because the lid is off,
as you saw in that previous
image, but one side is open.
And it's open with a silhouette
of a man crouched down.
Now, Henry Brown was 5'8.
I'm 5'8.
And I was compelled to
get inside that box.
And this idea of--
from Henry, thinking
outside of the box
meant literally to
think inside the box
and to put himself into a
situation that was disrupting
the current practices.
But he was at a point at which
he was willing to try anything.
Now, this story of Henry
Brown can be retold
and can be recreated
and be reproduced.
And there are some folks who--
you know, I make
these connections.
The image on the
left is actually
someone who is trying
to get themselves out
of this particular
situation putting themselves
inside a suitcase and
mailing oneself out
of a horrible situation.
The image on the
right is actually
a white student in black face
as a Halloween costume going
as Henry Box Brown.
Now, both of these
images relate directly
to the Henry Box Brown story
for me, but in different ways.
They can be unpacked--
no pun intended--
to deal with various
levels of class,
of identity, of
social situation,
of systems of oppression,
and expectations.
This idea of reading
in public places--
just like I did with the Henry
Brown work last year and also
here--
I think is an important
piece to consider.
And the way in which we
read to children, I think,
is important.
Words are very important.
Words are powerful.
There are games that we
play through social media
in public spaces like
Words with Friends.
I play this game quite often.
But there are some words
that are unacceptable.
You think-- what?
There are some words
that aren't-- well,
if you misspell it, it's
probably unacceptable.
Negro is an unacceptable
term in Words with Friends.
Really?
Because that's a
term I think people
need to deal with and
address and unpack.
Asian is also an unacceptable
term in Words with Friends.
Now, I find these two examples
interesting for the kind
of work that I'm doing.
But there are some other
words that are acceptable.
And really big words matter.
And just like
socially engaged art
that moves away from
the materiality and more
to the conceptual
and the experiential,
moving from specific labels to
larger concepts and constructs
seems to be of more value to
Words with Friends as well.
For example, "conceptualizing"
can earn you 1,469 points.
That's a lot of points.
So maybe there's something
in conceptualizing
that we need to do.
So how do we conceptualize
telling difficult stories?
Another children's
book, Goodnight Moon,
you might be familiar with this.
Goodnight, moon.
Goodnight, cow
jumping over the moon.
There's this
interesting repetition.
Well, Larry Wilmore created
a version of Goodnight Moon.
He called it Goodnight Slavery.
Larry Wilmore was a talk show
spin-off from The Jon Stewart
Show.
And so this show
with Larry Wilmore,
he decided that one
of the skits that he
did was to create
a children's book
called Goodnight Slavery
inspired by the Texas
legislature and the
Texas Education board
changing the curriculum.
And changing certain
terms, moving
the term the
transatlantic slave trade
and renaming it the
transatlantic triangular trade.
And so he has this entire
piece where he pulls apart
that movement, the essentially
whitewashing of history.
And so what you see there
are lines from the book.
"In a big red state,
there was a textbook
in a debate and too many knaves
in one big cave and a book
that is shut and a past
full of smut and a cranky
conservative with a
stick up his butt.
Good night, slavery.
Good night, bravery.
Good night to things
we find unsavory."
Well, what are
some of the things
that they might find unsavory?
Well, I'll get to
that in a second.
But this book Goodnight Moon
has been told in different ways.
It's a fixture within
children's book culture
that gets repurposed
and reimagined.
Some of the ways that
Wilmore understands
what is being erased--
Goodnight KKK, Goodnight to the
decimation of indigenous people
on this continent.
So these are all the things
that the Texas curriculum was
erasing or modifying or
eliminating or renaming to make
them seem less unsavory.
And in one more skit,
he reads this book
to a classroom of
kindergarten children.
And their reactions
are wonderful.
But it's also-- you can
tell it's kind of coached
for the skit.
Reading public places--
different than reading
in public places.
We could also read
public places.
For example, in the summer--
for the past three summers--
I've had the opportunity
to teach at Vermont
College of Fine Arts.
And one of the
courses that I teach
looks at participatory
inquiry in the public sphere.
One of the assignments
is for us to go
to the State House, the
State Capitol, which
is just a mile and a half,
two miles away from campus.
And it's the smallest state
capitol in the country.
It's very accessible.
We sign up for a guided tour.
And before the tour, I give
each student a little figurine
that I bought at the toy
store, these little busts of US
presidents.
And I ask the students
to go on the tour,
to be polite on the tour.
But I would like you to read the
state capitol in conversation
with the tiny president.
So on our walk down, in our
mile and a half walk down,
they're on their
phones, and they're
googling Theodore Roosevelt
or Thomas Jefferson or Abraham
Lincoln.
And then they take
cell phone shots.
There's a close-up
of tiny George,
and in the back is big George.
Or please keep off, and they
put one of the presidents--
I think that's Buchanan--
inside the cannon.
Or they end up
reading other people.
And it's with this tiny
president, this tiny object,
that they're able to
construct stories that
couldn't be told otherwise.
Putting that situation,
that context, history,
and related information
that they have either
brought to that
space or that they
learn on the tour
in conversation
with what they know
about that president.